Oh back to back playing Tetrarch again
he completely crushed me in the game
before that so out for revenge yeah
really played this wow this opening
badly so let's see what we get here we
get a Rico's in check and play this is
fairly solid line that um Magnus cards
at least recently used to beat level
uronian in the Tata Steel tournament
it's not about the opening really that
that cards born but I don't have a great
recipe against their goals and I never
studied it so playing for this curtain
sorry this kind of solid setup makes
some sense I don't know you go rook
fclose one I don't know yeah White's
general plan is to later yeah move the
Queen and then play night a4 to see to
see five yeah that was not played by by
aronian maybe you play the other look I
don't know aronia played it and a bit
more restrained fashion but he really
didn't get any kind of substantial
county play that's a pretty brutal way
to go about things
okay I was here and 2g to you know I
guess so some pretty good square for one
night now that looks active but it also
leaves weaknesses behind so it's not so
easy for him to get something going here
I think so f three now we have f 32 to
open up or is this a bad idea mmm also f
4 which is not terribly bad why can go
nite edge form yeah maybe do this just
stop it yeah and you can I can go Bishop
d3 92 to have for this kind of thing or
is this is there something better here
now maybe maybe do this trying two nite
c5 in itself it's not I want to go to d3
at the end this is what I want to
achieve so the night okay I can also
think about other ideas which is six
thinking to try before him yeah I have
to do a mean I have to be a bit bit
quicker 96's is hitting we just took it
okay that that is surprising surprising
to me at least didn't expect that move
at all so night tries to come to the six
after all and so maybe chick here and
now what now
Quincy to look you wan this kind of
thing I start with this
controlling those squares okay can i dno
as Bishop f5 trying to trade the light
squared bishops so that the f5 square is
something that my knight can really
really use now if he takes he loses the
Queen immediately so it's difficult here
for him to avoid the straight after
which well his open King position is
sound a real cause for concern and I
don't know what he actually should play
Queen f6 I will take and play night at
five chick then rookie one yeah this g5g
for business has heard the skin position
okay here i can i can also play rook e1
let's do that renewing this threat of
taking
okay takes rook chicks yeah maybe I
should pile up on that this is this
looks stronger bishop cakes and I takes
gives them struggling for a move with
this King and I'm going wiki one next
it's not idea and maybe I can also take
and playbook g5 yeah this is this is a
nice additional idea and that played it
quickly makes it even better movement
okay so let's see seems I have some
chances here to get my get my revenge in
yeah for this is an idea this jar Leah
crushed the team that he managed to
deliver on me so lucky one yeah just
piling up rook takes pawn Texas I think
it direct win so cannot do that not
quite sure if I'm threatening something
directly here Queenie for maybe a 24 as
a threat maybe maybe it's a trend okay
so what what he what about this how do I
play this Queenie form Queenie for
threatens Queen f4
okay so defended that for a moment
Queenie 54 Emma would be very nice to
get in it's almost a maid moving the
night is also attractive of course yeah
93 but am i winning with this I don't
know now a night h4 night age for could
be could be a move not completely sure
maybe you can play King g7 now and sort
of hang on it looks hard to believe
Queen takes I play rookie 6 night takes
that's just EA tanging so we cannot take
on d4 so it's very difficult to play him
okay justjust d5 if on 96 is also quite
tempting triangular d 555 is good
yeah and no no exactly they have to
check ring the doorbell now okay gave
away the Rukia black result yeah okay so
let's let's have a look at at this game
we have this opening here there it goes
in yeah and this is this is a standard
counter play with g5 but i think that
normally um black is doing this kind of
thing are getting the night over or here
and then advancing I'm not sure about
this really it looks it looks a bit
weakening I'm getting edged for blocked
yeah and she here it's it starts to get
interesting I went I went here simply
mechanically blocking each form there
are other ideas here f3 for example is a
move that I considered if black takes
I'm certainly in very good shape yeah
this is this is hanging not easy to take
admittedly but and this is hanging and
their file is open so this is kinda nice
but he has moved like that and it's not
I wouldn't really know what to do now
maybe now you play this but have that is
not so convincing I think this is an ok
move I went here this is this is
debatable I think this takes a lot of
time and it's not clear that it helps i
can go here actually I didn't I wasn't
sure about this he cannot do this I
think because of fif yeah this this is
looking and really awkward now it was
probably better to play it for around
here hear me he can take for example and
then play this and here he has chances
that's a wrong
pero chances to do this and trade this
night and then aged 4 is coming again
and this is probably what you should do
after if why he's i think in slide
trouble at least her in this practical
game with limited time his bad King
position is a is a is a cause for
concern okay my computer just wants to
take him as usual completely unfazed I
wanted to take here at computer just
ticks and says black is better yeah I I
didn't really think about this I mean
black is better means minus 0.2 or
something White has a compensation here
but ok that spends probably a good
solution yeah this this now gets very
very tricky yeah and computers giving
white a pretty big edge already rookie 5
seems to be best check and drug see one
also and now Queen d2 was given a
stronger by the computer but not a lot
this also seems to win and no okay oh
yeah that's interesting strongest move
now it's an h4 yeah that's yeah that's a
nice one yeah let cannot take because d5
then is even stronger I have gained this
additional possibility and the age for
takes away squares young g5 yeah that
sets that's really a complete complete
loss no that's its but ok I think I
think it's there are many ways leading
to to roam here this i am not sure about
i was thinking that here i'm not having
a super clear win yeah computer greece's
just +1 but this is this is just a super
strong a check Queen beef is actually
strong him
but this is also plus five yeah so he
blundered the rook with little time but
it's it's not really a position that
black can't defend something like this
would be six now let's this is just a
super strong a check that will will win
ultimately okay i hope you enjoyed this
game thanks for watching